turkey is set to open a new chapter in
its european union membership
negotiations the first time it's done so
in three years at a meeting in
Luxembourg de use general affairs
council decided the talks could begin on
regional policy and the coordination of
structural instruments this is one of 35
policy areas or chapters that all
aspiring EU candidates must comply with
to join the negotiations will be
launched in Brussels on the fifth of
November turkey began its membership
talks in 2005 it's so far opened 14
chapters I hope we'll catch up I'll
continue so an important the deliverable
after three years and let's hope it will
be really good basis for the
continuation The ministers also discuss
preparations for the European Council of
heads of state and government in two
days key items on the summit agenda
include the completion of the digital
single market combating youth
unemployment improved access to finances
for small and medium-sized businesses as
well as strengthening policies that
underpin the Euro single currency and
completing the banking Union
preparations for the Eastern Partnership
summit in Lithuania at the end of next
month and the plight of asylum seekers
tried across the Mediterranean to Europe
are also up for discussion the ministers
also endorsed a report on the European
semester process which helps member
states to better organize their budgets
and economic policies they agreed that
the process which concluded in July was
largely successful but that some
shortcomings still need to be addressed